هل هناك احد يحب التقدم في العمر يعدل انا
والله مبسوط انت مرتاح
في شخص اخر كمان هو الممثل الامريكي هارسن
فورد صاحب التمانين عاما صديقي يقول
انه لن يلتفت الى الوراء ليقول لنفسه انهم
يرغب في العوده الى الشباب يوضح حارسا في
تصريف الفن الشباب بالفتره الرائعه لكنه
محظوظ ايضا بكونه مسن فقط وليس ميتا ربما
الاغرب في تصريحات هاريسون انها جاءت خلال
تواجده في مهرجان كان لتقديم شخصيته
الشهيره عن ديانا جونز لكن هذه المره هذه
انا جونز استعاد ملامح الشباب بفضل
المؤثرات الخاصه
ايوه والله
لكل انا من مبدا انه لكل مرحله عمريه
حلاوتها يعني فتره الطفوله لها حلاوتها
المراهقه لها حلاوتها ايضا الشباب عاد
ممتد شباب حتى هو الشباب شباب حتى تسعه
وستين عاما حتى تسعه
لا بس على فكره هو الانسان حتى وان مثلا
بيكبر بالعمر فبيصير في مشاكل صحيه وجسمه
يثقل عليه ولكن بكون مرتاح مع نفسه يعني
كتير اكتر عم بشوف هذا الحكي بكثير
دراساته احنا في عالمنا العربي ان الواحد
يصل عمره اربعين خمسين سنه تلاقينا بحاجه
الى عكاز حتى يمشي بينما هذا العمر هو
بدايه الانطلاق الى ما بعد فتره العمل
بكاد
الاستمتاع بالحياه فتره النضود
عمليه التقدم هذا ما بدا يتغير في عالمنا
العربي اليوم تلاقين هذه الاعمار اللي هو
في فتره الثلاثينيات نهايه الثلاثينيات
الاربعينيات الخمسينيات وحتى قاعد اقول لك
السبعينيات والستينيات يمشون يمارسون
حياتهم الدكتور عبد الله القويس اليوم صعد
الى ما نقول قمه ايفرست لكن اللي هو
المخيم الاول وعمره رجل ثمانيني احنا
خطوتين نمشي ونلهث
طريقه
التفكير ان شاء الله الصحه والسلامه
للجميع لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات